ho cercato di tenere i capelli e mio
fratello durante la quarantena
niente qualcosa mi dice che non ci sono
riusciti non ci credo ciao ragazzi
bentornati a una nuova puntata di vita
buttata il tema della puntata di oggi e
rasature improponibili
prima di cominciare con questa puntata
però volevo dire una cosa
tanti auguri a me oggi faccio 33 anni
mette temi un pollice su per il anche
solo per farmi gli auguri detto ciò la
puntata di oggi è in collaborazione con
one lei che posso dire senza vergogna e
nell'onestà totale essere il rasoio
migliore che io abbia mai provato lo
scoperto quattro anni fa durante grease
io dovevo fare danni dovevo stare sempre
senza barba usavo sempre lametta stavo
morendo e mio amico ogni creduto a me mi
ha detto perchè non provi questo quadro
ho provato ragazzi lo consiglio a
chiunque so che sembra uno spottone ma
lo faccio solamente perchè ci credo un
po nullo senti non serve la schiuma da
barba lo fai sotto la doccia lo fai a
secco come te pari a ragazzi
prendetevelo ragazzi e regalate ai
vostri fidanzati fratelli genitori
qualsiasi anche a vostra nonna se c'è la
barba ma fidatevi vale la pena vale
assolutamente la pena e sono contento di
collaborare con loro ecco perché
all'interno degli studios di casa mia
potevo solamente invitare una persona
una persona che ha sempre avuto una
barba che io ho criticato incolta alla
quale non ha mai prestato troppa
attenzione una persona che ha uno stile
pari a zero disprezzabile mio cugino
giammarco che cos'è la mia balvano lo ha
capito che no in realtà oggi devo dire
che se è stato fin troppo bra matera si
è fatta un po di giorni fa oggi ti
facciamo zero come a 0 barba
sopracciglia innanzitutto ti omaggio
anch'io a grazie in questo momento non
abbiamo tre questo qui per predire che
veramente io ci credo un sacco questo è
il mio personale fare quindi mi si apre
io non ho mai usato allora devi
guardarlo mellon e si dovrebbe aprire
questa qui è la testina dei miracoli che
va avanti giu calcola che va avanti già
pronta la puntata c'era diano ok ma io
posso radelet e vi ringrazio perché io
so come mi faccio la barba con questa
rosa comunque prim'ancora di renderci
direi di iniziare a sentire gli audio
che ci sono arrivate ai bye bye quegli
infami dei miei vecchi coinquilini per
scherzo mi lasciarono
parte della barba e dei capelli con te
che mi trovai costretto ad us army poi
completamente a 0 no questo è traumatico
noi abbiamo la foto è un bugiardo mica
tutti devono mandare per forza la foto
ma che ci sono le persone che ci tengono
alla loro privacy
vabbè per in una foto a caso eccolo sì
effettivamente quando avevo 17 anni
usavo la crema depilatoria verrà del mit
sotto le ascelle perché ho sempre avuto
paura dei rasoi pensavano bastasse quel
poco di crema depilatoria che avevo che
invece non mi è bastata quindi sono
rimasta come justin a del film di
verdone mascella si è macellano mi sono
data malata in ascolto ho fatto furka
sono andati a comprare la crema
depilatoria e ho rimediato
l'inconveniente nel bagno di una
stazione ma che davvero tutti sembra
stato sono infatti potuto provarlo
adesso adesso non a me
a me questo è uscito è un altro modello
che ci hanno mandato il loro face body
mazza però come tele radiologia che non
so cosa ho appena visto allora anni
avanti ciao ragazzi volevo raccontare
del mio taglio coda soyo dei peli sulle
gambe e un seno abbastanza poderoso ogni
tanto non vedevo i pezzi che ogni volta
c'era un mio amico che mi prendeva in
giro io non vedevo niente
non vedo che le scarpe figurati se vedo
le cose pensate andiamo a vedere noi il
profilo suo era un gran lynch paura ma
se una zip e che si tiene il telefono
nelle mentana ospite il taglio di merda
è arrivato a fine quarantena quando
tutti quanti dei grandissimi capelloni
non riuscendo a prendere subito
appuntamento col barbiere e li faccio
tagliare dalla ragazza e niente mi sono
trasformato in un fungo lei veramente da
arrestare che criminale devo dirti c'è
un qualcosa di tenero confronto come
feci un lavoro da barbiere truffe c
il confronto a lei guarda e stortissimo
feci io ho un lavoro migliore con enrico
si ricordi molto meglio il mio solo pure
abbastanza soddisfatto è veramente una
scodella e non è che sei tu la sua
ragazza
ciao ciao ospite e un bacio alla linea
mio figlio 24 anni fulmine di guerra fa
mamma mi regolo la barba con la sede di
papà che il mio e scarico come se tra
l'altro aggiunto io mi sento un urlo
straziante colo in bagno a vedere mio
figlio si era rasato proprio il mezzo
che musei spostati divertito terrore
grandissimo ragazzi ora ci passano tutti
a io non ho capito se lui si è rasato
proprio in mezzo che vuoi fare non ci
provate lui praticamente stava tipo
tranquillo
avevamo detto che l'avresti fatta
comunque io ho capito però c'è come il
quale che stai benissimo se incriminare
avevano le anni volevo giocare con un
rasoio a tutte le cose su cui potevo
lottare
sono andato a tale proprio sul
sopracciglio destro ho fatto due anni
orribili dove non avevo più sopracciglio
tutti mi prendevano in giro sembravo un
emarginato due anni c'è la foto è un
bugiardo
magari sono stati anni molto duri me li
vuole spiattellare il mandato di
complicità sarà qui
saranno lentissime le sopracciglia noto
azzardare detto le sopracciglia e non ci
crederebbe cosa fracci l'hai detto
possiamo dire un rvm artici sopracciglia
italiano assume lo senti delicatissimo
ragazzi ci tengo a dire chi e gianmarco
siamo congiunti e negativi al co
bizzarri e lo sai che non ti sta male
cosa che qualcosa ne moda mi ricordo
quando ero piccola dieci anni mio padre
mi chiese di tagliare i capelli con la
macchinetta dei capelli in basso che
devono essere tolti praticamente mi è
scappata una macchinetta dalle mani e
sono salito fin sopra la testa per padre
comunque dovuto scappare dal
parrucchiere perché non potevo uscire
non lo importato perché non ci ho
pensato però è rimasto un bellissimo
ricordo sicuramente non ha una foto ma
ci manda un esempio per if i can't e
mamma mia
io avrei pianto non sarai mai più così
da un barbiere non ti farebbe vergognare
e stata la figlia tranquillo adesso
l'anno in un orfanotrofio che nel 40 non
precisati i taglieri capire nel ragazzo
non avendolo mai fatto prima questo è
quello che è uscito fuori e la prima
foto è l'errore che ho fatto dal momento
che qualcosa troppo tardi che la
macchinetta era senza adattatore anche
la seconda foto e come ho cercato di
rimediare non so perché se ancora con me
un dramma ha fatto un dramma un dramma
questo cui si tutti impegni riesci a
ridisegna gli una faccia dietro capito
c'è spazio per il voldemort di harry
potter 1 risotto comunque ragazzi
l'amore a volte spinge veramente a
fidarsi delle persone di cui non ce
l'avremmo mai filare in avanti e cosa
vuoi fare
la rada questa puntata è un'ansia
veramente da un momento all'altro poteri
senza capelli
provo a farti un lato o io riuscire a
farla senza vedere la barba io non ho
problemi riuscire a farmela così ad
occhi chiusi occhi chiusi guardando
verso l'infinito cioè senza guardare poi
ci arriviamo
non mi vedo bene qua puoi andare avanti
e indietro come ti pare ma non ti fai
male non l'altro non l'altro nell'altro
nome è andata si è fatto due buchi
sembra una coccinella fatti tutto rimane
col baffo
non vedo articolato sociale camelot e ad
occhi chiusi non ho questo super potere
a fini video sapete vi faccio vedere
come la facendo le seconde io sotto la
doccia nella faccia con questo a me non
è un problema con il monte che come ben
si sa provarsi vorrei essere più pablo
della serie ma vedendo faccio kacar e lo
sto bene dare giusto una giusta ton
regola barba crollata o promo cercando
di tenere i capelli e mio fratello
durante la quarantena
niente qualcosa mi dice che non ci sono
riusciti a fatti non ci credo tu sei
ancora viva delinquente messo colum
gollum cabal tevere nel mattone voglio
farmi la progetto serio ho visto su
internet si castra lo strega di come era
tipo a perfetta e di come era il giorno
dopo che ha visto la foto di una
strafiga che era vegetale appena fatto
finissima giorno dopo bel cespugli ne ha
fatta fichissima trovo particolare
alternativo fin adesso devo prepararmi
tra andare al lavoro che ci avevo un
sogno che non ti dico volevano ha tenuti
se marmi la barba vado per accorciarla
con il rasoio della christian ho bisogno
io accorcia 5 mm io ero talmente
assonnato che non mi
mi rendo conto che la testina era
affetta da zero con prima o poi la barba
il contouring della faccia così come le
ragazze usa del contouring noi ragazzi
senza barba se più giovane ma una
facciata di luna piena infinita posso
far vedere come lo faccio cosa che
ricordava il call satisfaction ragazzi
voi non avete orecchio musicale è pazzo
capitoli certo identico non senti la
fine o nome di mira sala senza fine
no
adesso mostrare la velocità alla quale
io riesco a farmi la barba senza vedere
al mese fa pensare ad altro fatto che
questo questa è la mia barba molto bene
però fallito erano prima o poi ci
provavo diciamo che sotto la doccia o
rasato altre zone del mio corpo ciao
ciao ospite allora io ho sempre portato
la barba lunga proprio il barbone quello
ignorante sembro e sono sempre sembrato
una sorta di vichingo che doveva
conquistare i villaggi e aveva anche il
suo perché perché comunque sia non
avendo un aspetto raffigurante nessuno
via le scatole poi però a un certo punto
mi hanno veramente affiancato il
cervello che ho deciso di tagliarla
milano specchiato e ho dovuto prendere
la carta entità per capire che fossi
ancora io mi sentivo abbastanza ridicolo
tantissimo leather corde un idiota che
camminava con la faccia di un bimbo di
due anni che invece ne aveva 40 che ha
ricominciato a farmela crescere e adesso
cielo di media lunghezza una cosa
tranquilla che però giustamente a me
piace poi a domanda rimane sempre che
vuole la gente non si sa e non si saprà
mai
infatti a questa domanda c'è solo una
risposta cosa vuoi tu punto jogging i no
333 trillo pazzoide chow il bus
ti scrivo riguardo al tema tagli
orribili nel 2018 ho imparato che mai
bisogna auto regolarsi le sopracciglia
con il rasoio elettrico per i capelli
per tu scazzo è sì ma mai la mia le
sopracciglia non eletto cate che se
avete di cespugli chiedete un estetista
giura che non mi sto cercando la gamba e
che un gattino alcuni giurano che sta
toccando un gattino guglielmo ciao
gianmarco e un saluto anche agli amici
di fiction grid e ho cominciato a
perdere i capelli molto molto presto
all'età di 19 anni circa siccome non
sopportavo vedere varie stempiature cose
leggere ho cominciato alla sun mille
subito a 0 0 che
non è un problema visto che a me esce
una barba non completissima però
ovviamente si può guardare ecco un
giorne b la malsana idea di kasami la
barba a zero e le persone che mi
conoscevano cominciavano accostarmi a
bari il mago otelma platinette mio
collega in quel periodo mi chiamava
pollicione per fare questo esperimento
allora apritela fotografato che insomma
senza barba tacco stati il pollice
vicino alla mia faccia e vi accorgerete
che sono esattamente in etico a few
pollici
fate la guerra casa vi mando un saluto
né un abbraccione mugello in particolare
io ti seguo dal 2008 se uno sbaglio sono
circa 12 anni che ascoltavo anche radio
ora non ho mai smesso di se questi detto
questo voglio bene entrambi continuate a
fare questo format perché mi piace
tantissimo tutti i parenti scilla a san
fratello questo grazie grazie ragazzi
siamo arrivati alla fine di questo video
non posso muovermi perché ho un gatto
che ha deciso di mettersi sulle mie
gambe e quindi non ho alcune intenzione
di muovermi evitare che questo raro
momento di attenzione possa terminare
non ti azzardare nemmeno a dirlo
detto ciò già mi ti ringrazio posso
dirti che il baffo ti sta bene dice che
devo uscire che fa così
c'è sempre una busta di la ringraziamo
soprattutto gli amici phoenix one blade
grazie per aver sponsorizzato questo
video e grazie per aver sponsorizzato
soprattutto nelle mie rasature negli
ultimi quattro anni questa
collaborazione per me vuol dire molto
più di quanto non pensiate
detto ciò come sempre se volete
scrivetemi pure degli auguri di
compleanno qua sotto sentitevi
liberissimi di farli tra parentesi non
avete fatto mezzo augurio ma non è così
avranno si riuscirà a tutti puoi fare
gli auguri da solo no è una vita che mi
faccio gli auguri da solo perché lui non
sa che con me ha mai fatto un regalo
certa resistenza se vi è piaciuto questo
video iscrivetevi al canale attiva tra
campagna le notifiche metteteci un
pollice in su per il e fateci sapere
quali sono altri temi di vita buttata
che mi piacerebbe vedere all'interno di
questo format detto ciò ho detto tutto
non lo so ci vediamo questa domenica non
la puntata di cucina buttata alle 12
ciao ciao
e comunque io regalando di coppiette
ieri che è un regalo le coppiette e
donati aiuto regalato un futuro che già
mi comunque regalo questo grazie
[Applauso]